[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat reportée d'une année
le prélèvement à la source est entrée en
vigueur le 1er janvier 2019
après les retraités 25 millions de
salariés fonctionnaires ont découvert
enfin nous leurs nouvelles fiches de
paie l'impôt sur le revenu est désormais
directement prélevé sur le salaire
une petite révolution pour les
contribuables mais aussi pour tous les
acteurs de cette réforme
ce défi administratif at il été relevé
et c'est ce que nous allons tenter de
savoir ce soir avec nos invités avec
nous à patricia pierre bonsoir avant
soit vous êtes spécialiste pôle social
au sein d' exponent s'expose ans est un
groupe spécialisé notamment dans
l'expertise-comptable qui compte neuf
cabinets en ile de france dont quatre
dans les yvelines
olivier gautrais bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes président de la dexia dexi c'est
l'association des dirigeants et
entreprises du centre et sud yvelines et
en face de vous il a belle veine hier à
recevant soir pour soir à vous êtes
secrétaire au sein du syndicat
solidaires finances publiques dans les
yvelines merci à tous les 3es d'être
présent ce soir alors avant d'entrer un
peu plus en détail dans ce débat
comment avez vous appréhendé ce mois de
janvier je vais commencer avec vous
olivier gaudry puisqu'on peut dire en
fait que le chef d'entreprise est un
petit peu le premier maillon de cette
chaîne en fait d'abord c'est très court
ce qui s'est passé trois semaines depuis
la rentrée pour être très honnête j'ai
eu quasiment aucun retour d'adhérents
sur les difficultés réelles je n'ai pas
eu en cours du mois de janvier
je crois que il ya deux il ya une
alternative ceux qui sont reliés à un
cabinet d'expertise-comptable et j'ai
l'impression que ça se passe plutôt très
bien
il ya ceux qui revanche font leur pays
eux mêmes et là c'est beaucoup beaucoup
plus compliqué et avec des incertitudes
d
voilà donc la situation elle est
vraiment très ambivalente entre ces deux
ces deux cas patricia pierre justement
sur quel point il fallait être
particulièrement vigilant tout ce mois
de janvier alors sur ce mois de janvier
nous nous avons traité donc les payes de
nos clients un petit petites entreprises
notre point de vigilance il a été sur
les remontée des taux qui sont réalisés
de manière automatique dans notre
logiciel de paye donc je moi je tiens à
dire que nous n'avons pas nous en tant
que que que tiers en quelque sorte
déclarant pour nos clients nous
n'intervenons pas sur la saisie des taux
donc nous savons d alerte sur ses taux
la et quelques remontées un peu sensible
de salariés qui font état d'erreurs sur
leurs taux qui sont en fait des dégâts
l'agent de temps dans le traitement par
les centres des impôts t d actualisation
des demandes des particuliers qui l'a
sera en effet un problème puisqu'il ya
trois mois de délai pour les impôts pour
corriger en corrigeant tôt voilà là
c'est un vrai problème ce sillage
entreprise qui prend deux places à cela
le soucier du salarié ce qui est
franchement pas normal et puis on peut
rien faire on sera obligé d'attendre
isabelle guérard il ya plusieurs
syndicats dont le votrient qui ont alors
dit que ce prélèvement à la source en
fait était justement source de surcharge
de travail est ce que c'est vrai
effectivement
l'organisation par le biais du
prélèvement mensuel était une
organisation précédemment qui marchait
très bien avec un taux de recouvrement
de 97%
donc la décision de passer au
prélèvement à la source c'est une
décision purement politique qui a eu
donc des implications techniques
difficiles comme viennent de le dire et
vos autres invités et puis surtout une
surcharge de travail parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup d'incompréhension de la part du
contribuable
malgré une très grande campagne de
communication fait par l'administration
le ministre a dit qu'il y allait avoir
une prime justement pour pour les à
cause justement de cette surcharge de
travail
alors qu'on prime de 200 euros une messe
alors je note re organisation syndicale
solidaires finances publiques
or revendique déjà une juste
rémunération pour les compétences de
l'ensemble des collègues première chose
effectivement il ya eu un surcroît de
travail mais nous estimons que la prime
de 200 euros ne correspond absolument
pas ni à notre technicité nyala
surcharge de travail et en plus elle ne
concerne pas l'ensemble des 103 mille
agents de la direction générale des
finances publiques mais ne concerne que
les agents qui sont directement impactés
par le prélèvement à la source
sauf que notre organisation interne fait
qu' il ya des implications qui ne sont
pas aussi visible mais tous les autres
services par exemple quand des collègues
sont à l'accueil et dans le courrier du
coup fait par des collègues qui ne
s'occupait pas traditionnellement il ya
des délestages aussi envers des services
de direction
donc non nous ne sommes pas satisfait ni
du montant ni du faible nombre
d'ailleurs gelé dia monsieur du soft
lors de sa visite alors justement ça
tombe bien que vous en parliez puisque
monsieur du soft ce qui est secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics étaient à
rambouillet en début de semaine il a
visité le centre des impôts il a
également rencontré des chefs
d'entreprise qu'il a tenu à rassurer je
vous propose de l'écouter l'étau micro
de marylène yapi chinon le problème à la
source fonctionne bien
il n'y a pas de bug il n'est pas
d'erreur les salariés sont informés
depuis l'avis d'imposition du mod70 du
taux qui va leur être appliquée si leur
situation a changé peut faire modifier
le taux pendant que compte la nouvelle
situation et le système informatique
technique
la relation entre les entreprises
d'administration tout cela fonctionne
donc nous sommes sereins serein mais
extrêmement concentré puisque nous
sommes toujours dans l'application de la
réforme et qu'il faut à la fois
redoubler de vigilance de concentration
pour garantir que l'intégralité du
processus se passe bien voilà donc le
gouvernement est donc confiant est-ce
que cela vous rassure on peut pas dire
qu'il ya des bugs
il n'y a pas de bug ça c'est certain il
y a par contre beaucoup de démarches à
faire parce que les taux ont été
calculées sur le dernier un peu connu
c'est à dire l'impôt de 2017
donc il faut l'actualiser parce que la
situation des personnes a pu changer
quant aux revenus mais là aussi changé
quand alors organisation familiale il
peut y avoir une des décès des mariages
des enfants des séparations des gardes
alternées etc
et c'est surtout ça qui pose problème
pas le système des cas nick du
prélèvement à la source lui même qui
fonctionne bien
le seule crainte maintenant qu'on va
avoir c'est le reversement parce que le
prélèvement il a été fait maintenant
pour tout le monde
d'une part par le prélèvement à la
source directement et par aussi la conte
contemporain parce que les personnes qui
ne sont pas salariés
les professions libérales ça le
prélèvement part de leur compte bancaire
c'est un peu assimilé à ce qu'on avait
avant
et donc c'est un conte contemporain tout
ça ça ne pose pas tellement de problèmes
ce qui pose problème c'est les
changements de la vie c'est vrai que
nous nous avons accompagné nos clients
depuis le mois de septembre justement
par des communications ciblées à
destination des salariés pour leur
expliquer cette échéance qu'ils avaient
au 15 septembre justement pour changer
leur situation changer leur taux prendre
le choix de ce taux là donc on a
travaillé vraiment mon amant et si c'est
ce qui je pense fait qu'aujourd'hui je
peux dire que oui ça fonctionne bien on
a très peu de remontées négatives mais
on constate qu'il ya des délais de
traitement relativement longs et
notamment
les embauches lorsqu'un employeur
embauche un salarié ce n'est pas son
salarié qui va lui donner son taux mais
que c'est pas ce taux là qui va être
saisie en paye à défaut d'une remontée
de taux automatique
il ya une action qui s'appelle le topaz
on va appliquer un taux neutre mais il
faut savoir que ce taux pas prend un
délai actuellement de 5 jours ouvrables
donc des embauches qui sont signalés ou
qui se font en fin de mois
l'employeur ne peut qu appliquer un taux
neutre sur la paye ce qui peut avoir un
impact important et puis forum toujours
retenir que ça va tout à fait d'accord
que je vais jeudi à trois mois il ya
offert aucun sens à ce que ce soit le
chef d'entreprise qui se trouve
responsable du recouvrement de l'impôt
mais ce n'est pas votre ancêtre alrosa
cela je voulais faire je m'endors pas en
disant que c'est le rôle de madame elle
le faisait très bien certainement est
pas le problème
une pompe il s'est pris un rôle du chef
d'entreprise de s'amuser à recouvrir les
impôts
des individus et chefs d'entreprise ont
été suffisamment accompagné en a reçu
des mails dans tous les sens je prends
pas moi j'ai un expert comptable donc ça
c'est très sympa situation j'espère
comptable sais pas vous mais ces calculs
c'est très bien mais qui aussi excellent
c'est bien pour les chefs d'entreprise
qui sait tout sur tout là ils reçoivent
des mails noël si vous n'êtes pas le
temps de les gérer presque 30 actions de
communication fait par là des défis
peuvent des yvelines envers tous les
publics c'est à dire les associations de
gestion
les représentants des consommateurs
enfin il ya eu une énorme campagne de
communication qui a été faite
est-ce que prélèvement à la source coûte
plus d'argent pour un chef d'entreprise
je vous ai jugé pour être franc j'ai
laissé dans la voiture j'ai reçu un mail
il a 25 salariés pendant que je prenne
tout petit effet s'était lui-même il
m'écrit je ne dit pas mot à mot ce que
je m'en souviens plus mais dans l'esprit
si tu savais le temps que ça me prend et
donc l'argent que ça me coûte
et ça je vais jamais de payer je
recevrai pas de prix tout ça c'est sûr
et ça me prend un temps de dingue parce
qu'il faut que je vois lille fn lui-même
bon mais voilà et quand elle fait appel
à un cabinet d'experts-comptables
qu'elle qui justifie finalement cette
cause parce qu'il ya des nouvelles
fiches de salaire par exemple alors sur
sur l'accompagnement que nous avons mis
en place toute cette communication que
nous avons eue auprès de nos clients a
pris forcément du temps en terme de
préparation nous avons organisé des
sessions d'animation de formation pour
nos clients un employeur nous allons
former nos collaborateurs nous avons
aussi investi sur un logiciel performant
pour être en capacité de répondre à ces
à cette contrainte là et tous étant de
contrôle des fiches salariés nous avons
contrôlé les cohérence entre les numéros
de sécurité sociale les noms
patronymiques de façon à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas de difficultés de problèmes dans
les flux ce temps là où il a été l
répercuter en partie alors exponent son
a toujours pour optique et pour
j'étais les politiques de ne pas faire
supporter à nos clients la totalité de
ses impacts financiers là donc on sait
de quel de quel ordre
on a mis en place une facturation je
dirais pour la mise en place du pass qui
était de l'ordre de 100 euros à partir
de un salarié jusqu'à 400 500 600 euros
pour des entreprises à 259 énormément
moins bon cabinet d'expertisé je dirais
pas sans nous sommes prudents pour vous
couper moi me l'a pas fait payer mais
qui est aussi un cabinet une certaine
taille et les petits cabinets
d'expertise-comptable je vois pas
comment ils peuvent faire autrement que
le répercutaient parce que le logiciel
quand il décide sans payer
l'actualisation du logiciel ans et du
temps reculés et ce temps là on l'a
passé pour que tout se déroule bien là
au mois de janvier mais il faut savoir
que chaque mois nos collaborateurs nos
gestionnaires de paie vont avoir un
contrôle de ces remontées de taux pour
s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas de difficulté
donc chaque mois nous avons un travail
supplémentaire
alors justement va voir une petite
infographie parce que vous parlez des
mois qui suivront qui vont suivre
puisque on le rappelle le prélèvement la
source évidemment ne fait pas
disparaître la déclaration annuelle de
revenus puisque entre le mois d'avril et
le mois de juin il faudra déclarer à ses
revenus 2018 il y aura un nouveau taux
de prélèvement applicable à partir de
septembre un taux qui peut être on le
rappelle vous en avez parlé d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure modifiés en cours d'année
si la situation du contribuable change
mariage naissance ou bien la variation
des revenus alors justement par rapport
à la déclaration annuelle de revenus de
il était question d'une année blanche
pour 2018 c'est ce que c'est sa valeur
toujours d'actualité juste pour
compléter ce que disait ces messieurs
dames
l'état est aussi payeur puisque à la des
défis des yvelines nous faisons cela
paye des fonctionnaires à la fois des
fonctionnaires de la direction des
finances publiques mais aussi beaucoup
pour l'éducation nationale donc là non
plus en tant qu'employeur faisons
l'appel
il n'y a pas eu de difficulté donc je
voulais lui dire ça alors effectivement
il faudra faire une déclaration il ya
beaucoup de mauvaise compréhension du
public qui a pensé que prélèvement à la
source
c'était juste ne plus s'occuper de rien
en réalité
allah
soit il devient acteur beaucoup plus
qu'il ne l'était plus et donc il devra
faire sa déclaration avec ses revenus à
partir de ce moment là l'impôt sera
calculée selon les barèmes la loi de
finances a été votée et et l'année
blanche ça veut dire qu'en fait si les
revenus sont standard c'est à dire à peu
près les mêmes que l'année précédente
on va calculer son impôt je schématise
un peu parce que techniquement c'est un
peu plus compliqué on compte un crédit
d'impôt du même montant que l'impôt et
donc ça fait zéro par contre si vous
avez vous êtes partis à la retraite par
exemple là
cette année enfin en 2013 2018 les
déclarer le prime que vous avez touché
pour le départ à la retraite alors les
revenus exceptionnels seront axés
comment calcule-t-on ses revenus
exceptionnels schématiquement on prend
les revenus des quatre dernières années
on fait la moyenne
s'ils ont ce qui dépasse cette moyenne
rentrer au roi dans le calcul dans mon
temps quand même pour 2018 donc ce n'est
pas totalement une année blanche s'il ya
eu des revenus exceptionnels ou des
licenciements avec des grosses
indemnités qui sont imposables ou
d'autres actions de les ventes de titres
ou des choses comme ça sur cette partie
là qui dépasse la moyenne des quatre
dernières années mais bon c'est assez
technique donc faisons confiance à nos
collègues dans les services comme dans
une société où on aime et c'est
incroyable vous visionnez le temps mais
même pour provoquer je pense que tous
les agents des impôts qu'ils doivent
rire je pense qu'ils autre chose j'ai
quelque chose avant hic c'est quelque
chose quand on est engagé dans le temps
à la présidence de la république il est
question de supprimer 120 mille
fonctionnaires dont cinquante mille
fonctionnaires et on en supprime cette
année 2000 plus de 2100 aux finances
publiques dont 18 dans notre département
mais on en a déjà supprimé 40 mille donc
le travail il faut bien qu'ils se
fassent donc si le choix fait que les
citoyens ne veulent pas avoir de
fonctionnaires et ben s'est déporté sur
les autres donc s'est déporté sur le
secteur privé et sur les sur les
employeurs les comptables et puis les
contribuables à ce que je vais vous dire
à vous plaire c'est ça transforme plus
la société dans une société de
l'électronique et de l'informatisation à
outrance ce qui était une vrai problème
parce que pour tout le monde le sait ce
qu'est l'informatique ne veut pas dire
perfection il ya régulièrement des
erreurs et une erreur d'un système
informatique pour le ressortir le
prouver enfin ça devait être
catastrophique
hélas l'humanisation qui pouvaient
exister quand même ça qu'ils achètent
dans les relations entre
les fonctionnaires les composants de la
population face aux relations là c'est
quelque chose qui disparaît et qu'il est
amené à disparaître de plus en plus
appartient moment où on part du principe
que en informatique tout donc fait
beaucoup plus simple et vont tout va
fonctionner très bien c'est faux une
question si le prélèvement à la source
soulevé un problème de confidentialité
puisque du coup quand l'employeur voit
le tout il peut voilà il peut se douter
que par exemple les revenus du conjoint
de son employé voilà c'est ça il sait
qu'il a un conjoint déjà accessoirement
c'est vrai j'ai trois salariés avec moi
je
je sais maintenant que tu vis dans la
lune je sais qu'elle voit là ça me
regarde pas sincèrement ça me regarde
pas ces problèmes
c'est un faux problème et à ce que parce
que quand vous travaillez dans une
entreprise vous avez des collègues
donc vous êtes contents d'annoncer
naissance vous vous dites que vous avez
l'air malade donc la confidentialité
c'est en fait à l'heure alors dans les
contrats tout à fait content qu'on
puisse bien vous entrerez connais pas on
ne connaît pas la ville des gens que par
le revenu les personnes ont il ya une
vie sociale par exemple un employeur c
qui d'ailleurs un bébé parce qu'il y
aura des congés maternité des choses
comme ça il peut y avoir aussi des aides
du comité d'entreprise ou des choses
comme ça et on peut aussi avoir du
social dans une entreprise
donc c'est un faux problème la la la
confidentialité c'est un problème
typiquement français dont on se moque la
tête et je ne crois pas que on aurait pu
résoudre ce problème si les personnes
avaient choisi le tour individuelle
parce qu'avec le taux individuel on
tenait compte que de leurs propres
revenus
or
il ya là s'apprêtait aussi bien que 10%
de contribuables dans les yvelines qui
ont choisi le taux individuel ce qui est
un peu un taux beaucoup plus important
que dans le reste de la france où c'est
à peu près 6 % et danser explique que ce
sont en fait chacun a ses propres
revenus
donc quand le calcul a été fait que tout
le monde a eu l'avis d'imposition il y
avait été marquée en fonction du revenu
de monsieur le taux qui serait prêt dès
le taux de madame et le taux famille
enfin qui est le taux d'une coupole du
foyer et donc si vous choisissiez votre
taux personnel votre employeur ne peut
pas savoir quel est le revenu ou que
supposé dans votre conjoint et un gros
revenus ou un petit revenu donc c'est
parce qu'aussi on est à la fois dans un
système on est encore foyer fiscal
donc le taux foyer mais je pense que
cette réforme enfin ça c'est mon opinion
personnelle va conduire à ce qu'on
arrive dans alors l'administration le
dément le ministre le dément mais vers
un taux individuelle obligatoire comme
dans d'autres pays et dans les autres
pays où il ya les prélèvements à la
source
il n'y a pas davantage familiaux le fait
d'avoir un enfant n'est pas un avantage
familial donc ça modifierait l'ensemble
donc ça présume
à mon sens d'une raison plus intense et
que ce sont les bases est-ce qu'il peut
y avoir des problèmes de de fraude
avec ce système de prélèvement la source
je sais pas l'employeur qui alors de
fraude je dirais je ne crois pas plus
que remarquée lors de ma deuxième social
et l'employeur prélève déjà des
cotisations sociales la france ce serait
de ne pas les reverser aux différents
organismes
voilà
que des clients par exemple l'employeur
fait entre guillemets une fausse une
fausses fiches de salaires avec un taux
un taux erronées ce que ça peu avec un
salaire qui l'a inventé avec un dress
alary en fait si par exemple le salarié
imaginons un taux normal mans 2-0 des
0,5 et sur la fiche de salaire
l'employeur fraude en disant que son
salarié en fait à un taux de je ne sais
pas de 10% pour bien même c'est le
faisons du contrôle fiscal dans
l'administration fiscale on a quand même
pas celle des marches de considérer les
entreprises ou des fraudeurs potentiels
n'ont lésiné problèmes qu'on a de fraude
ce sont les gens qui déjà enfin les
entreprises qui déjà fraude à l'urssaf
rôde déjà maintenant ne reverse pas tous
les précaires c'est à dire les sous
traitants ce sont souvent ces personnes
là ils montrent une boîte y créer mais
finalement ils reversent rien à personne
et mettre les clés sous la porte
mais c'est vraiment peanuts enfin je
veux dire le souci enfin j'ai
l'administration fiscale continuera ses
contrôles bien sûr mais avec l'idée
quand même que les employeurs ne sont
pas tous des bandits de grand chemin
aujourd'hui non mais c'est ce qu'on
pense tous alors cette émission touche
bientôt à sa fin
on va commencer à conclure alors je
commence avec vous monsieur gautier est
ce que ce défi du prélèvement à la
source a été a été relevé
je peux pas encore vous dire nous donner
la réponse c'est trop tôt et ça fait
même pas un mois on le sera quand il y
aura des modifications des taux de voir
les conséquences sur la vie des abeilles
avait beaucoup d'inquiétudes il ya
quelques mois d'ailleurs quand vous
étiez notamment sur sur ce plateau aussi
pour un débat sur ce thème est ce que là
les inquiétudes ce sont les inquiétudes
qui est vrai que j'avais soulevé une
partie des inquiétudes que j'avais
soulevé qu'il était lié aux la
préparation d
logiciels notamment et ce qui serait
vraiment était prêt à la date du 31
décembre
et ça il ya pas dans l'esprit d'un poids
de souci ça c'est parfait après j'ai
soulevé deux inquiétudes qui était sur
les conséquences des erreurs sur les
taux et notamment de la responsabilité
du dirigeant dans ce cas là qui est
responsable
on ne sait toujours pas trop et
normalement je crois qu'elle va système
de pénalités qui était censé se mettre
en place ou plus ou moins dociles et des
tisserands de ce qui va venir
enfin voilà à tous et c'est plutôt dans
cet ordre là si vous voulez seller suite
après il ya ce que j'avais dit à
l'époque était très simple sur le fait
que oui je me retrouve à connaître par
moments une partie de la vie de mes
salariés que ça me regarde pas patricia
pierre et est ce que finalement c'est
encore un peu flou ce prélèvement alors
flouze non je pense qu'on en est qu'au
début on n'a pas tous les retours encore
par rapport à la paye du mois de janvier
mais l'étape comme vous le disiez madame
la prochaine étape c'est le mois de mai
2010 neuf quand il va falloir que l'on
fasse les déclarations de revenus 2018
avec ces questions revenus exceptionnels
ou pas c'est la prochaine étape c'est la
prochaine étape donc avec je pense à un
accompagnement encore des entreprises
qui est nécessaire sur ces questions là
il avait levé je pense qu' il n'y a pas
de raison que ça ne marche pas tout a
été mis en oeuvre sur le plan technique
maintenant il faut l'acceptation de la
population il faut par contre ne pas
minimiser l'investissement des
fonctionnaires delà de notre ministère
et de la dgesip en particulier parce que
ce n'est pas parce qu'elle prélèvement à
la source qu'il n'y a plus besoin de
rien faire au contraire il y a tout un
travail de back office
un travail d'accompagnement parce que la
vie des personnels est fluctuante
elle ne se base pas sur la fiscalité
elle se base sur leurs vies humaines et
sociales et donc nous notre rôle de
fonctionnaires c'est d'abord d'être
neutre et de continuer d'apporter et de
porter le service public pour être
vraiment au plus près de la vie des gens
est juste une dernière phrase le
gouvernement a beaucoup communiqué sur
cette phrase l'impôt à la source peut
vous simplifier la vie
parce que vous avez avec la borne
alors ça c'est très clair qu'il ya des
difficultés financières le simple fait
que il n'est pas de rejet de son
prélèvement mensuel le 15 du mois où le
8 du mois et parce que c'est enlever sur
sa feuille de paye peut-être une
simplification maintenant les personnes
qui sont vraiment précaire et qu'ils ont
une situation vraiment difficile
ça ne résoudra pas davantage la
situation
de toute façon c'était une posture
politique après je suis quand même
confiante dans le futur parce que c'est
comme toute nouveauté
au début on n'a pas aimé la pyramide du
louvre et aujourd'hui on se rend compte
que le louvre est plus agréable à
visiter par la pyramide donc j'ai
confiance et dans les fonctionnaires
mais aussi dans les partenaires et les
contribuables ils s'adapteront le
problème c'est de ne laisser personne en
route surtout pas les populations en
difficulté qui sont loin de
l'informatisation et c'est ceux qui
seront les premières victimes et c'est
donc pour cela qu'il faut qu'on soit
tous unis il faut qu'on attende coûter
de l'argent aux entreprises
et actuellement autre chose à en faire
merci en tout cas tous les trois à avoir
été à présent ce soir voilà c'est la fin
de ce numéro merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau cette fuite débat
[Musique]